hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast next generation
probiotics targeting C difficile
infection presented by dr. Jennifer
Spindler instructor pathology and
immunology baylor college of medicine we
are excited to bring you this
educational webcast
presented by lab roots the leading
scientific social networking website and
provider of virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning I'm julissa Morales of lab
roots and I'll be your moderator for
today's event
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the range and
a button located in the lower left of
the presentation window then type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen will answer as many questions
as we have time for at the end of the
presentation also please notice that you
will be viewing the presentation in the
slide window to enlarge the window just
click on the screen icon located in the
lower right if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of the presentation window or use the
Q&A button to let us know that you're
having a problem this is an educational
webinar and this offers great continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please click on the Cee button
located in the bottom left-hand corner
of your webpage and follow the process
of obtaining your credits please join me
in welcoming dr. Jennifer Spindler I
will now turn the presentation over to
her
Thank You Julie I am I'm excited to be
here today to share with you my work on
beneficial microbes specifically using
probiotics to target antimicrobial
associated diarrhea caused by
questionnaires Oh infection probiotics
are defined as live organisms that when
administered in adequate amounts confer
a health benefit on their host probiotic
bacteria have a wide range of beneficial
characteristics some include the
production of antimicrobial agents that
can inhibit the growth of pathogens
other beneficial microbes are able to
produce vitamins that enhance hosts
nutrition while yet still other strings
can secrete factors that have direct
impacts on the immune system and
decreasing inflammation in their hosts
now the probiotic concept is not a new
concept a Russian scientist and Nobel
laureate Elie metchnikoff first
pioneered this concept in the early 20th
century he was very aware of the long
lives of rural Europeans and he had
proposed that their longevity was in
part due to their consumption of lactic
acid bacteria they consumed like gossip
bacteria in fermented milk products as a
normal daily part of their diet now
fast-forward a hundred years and
researchers are beginning to study the
microbiome the microbiome project was
launched by the National Institutes of
Health in 2007 with the purpose of
cataloguing all of the bacteria in
on a healthy healing the purpose for
starting a major effort in uncovering
the bacteria that live in and on our
bodies was to help us gain an
understanding of how the human host and
our microbiota have co-evolved and how
microbiome stability is important and
sustaining human health
now the first first parts the first the
beginnings of human microbiome research
was definitely focused on determining
what microbes are their beneficial or
simply commensal organisms that are
present in and on a healthy human body
but the field has evolved to be able to
distinguish differences in microbiomes
of healthy humans versus those with
disease we do know that some disease
states can be reversed with microbiome
replacement therapy however I am more
interested in learning whether or not we
can in store a diseased State to a
healthy microbiome by manipulating it
with specific probiotics now as you can
imagine the field of human microbiome
research has had a significant impact on
the probiotic field there is a growing
public interest in microbe containing
foods and a rising use of probiotics in
the clinic surveys show that doctors are
making general recommendations for the
use of probiotics and gastrointestinal
disease as well as
biotic associated diarrhea and well this
is all well and good I hope that when
I'm finished speaking with you today
that you'll understand that we need more
specific recommendations we need better
research and studies into the specific
beneficial characteristics of specific
probiotics targeting very specific
diseases so one application of
probiotics that is clearly relevant is
the use of them to prevent antibiotic
associated disease now we are currently
entering an antibiotic crisis Sir
Alexander Fleming warned us of this back
as early as 1945 when penicillin became
widely used his warning was that
antibiotic abuse would result in severe
antibiotic resistance and the drugs
would no longer be effective along with
the rise in emerging resistance of
bacterial pathogens we also had a
significant decrease in the discovery of
new antibiotics over the past 30 years
so here we have now the antibiotic
crisis where we're running out of drugs
capable of containing and treating
packaged enik infections these estimated
u.s. costs are up in the billions so
there's 20 billion dollars in healthcare
costs annually due to antibiotic
resistance and approximately 35 billion
dollars a year lost in productivity so
there is a dire need for alternative
therapies to prevent antibiotic
associated disease and the CDC has
categorized certain diseases as urgent
with Clostridium difficile disease being
one of them C difficile infection is
the leading cause of health
care-associated infections in the United
States with nearly half a million
hospitalizations and costed 4.8 billion
dollars annually this is definitely
considered one of the diseases of a
disrupted microbiome it occurs when the
normal gut microbiota are disrupted by
antibiotic use we do know that when you
can restore health to patients with
recurrent C difficile infection by
administering fecal microbial
transplants so using fecal microbial
material to restore a healthy microbiota
to the intestine can prevent recurring
infection however this kind of treatment
is not ideal and currently there are no
specific guidelines that recommend
probiotics for preventing C difficile
infection however there are quite a bit
of literature out there supporting their
use in preventing C difficile infection
for example this Cochrane review was
published in 2013 where they asked do
probiotics prevent c difficile
associated infection in patients on
antibiotics and they showed in their
meta-analysis that there one out of 23
studies and at over 4,000 participants
that there was a 64 percent reduced risk
in patients on antibiotics getting C
difficile infection
additionally they were able to determine
that there is a 20% decrease in almost
4,000 participants in symptoms of C
difficile infection and based on this
analysis these authors concluded that
probiotics are safe and effective for
preventing C difficile associated
disease additionally there are a few
other clinical trials out there showing
that specific formulations that continue
probiotic organisms are capable of
preventing recurrence eating at the seal
infection just study by johan Bakken
using life way cheaper I combined with a
staggered integrity antibiotic
withdrawal treatment showed that there
was an 84% of success rate in preventing
my current C difficile infection in
elderly patients there were also no
called comorbidities associated with
this treatment and he he concluded that
standard integrity antibiotic withdrawal
combined with keeper supplementation
could be as effective at preventing
recurrence e difficile infection as
vehicle microbial transplantation
additionally hospitals in Canada have
have implemented the use of bio k costs
in their systems after a major c
difficile outbreak in 2003 particular
hospitals started prescribing vial k
plus to all impatient adults that work
on antibiotics regardless of other
health issues so within 2 to 12 hours of
initial antibiotic doses these patients
received a minimum of 30 days of bio p
plus and this resulted in 70 73 percent
reduction and CDI incidents and a 39
percent reduction and see if it still
affects your clients they also have
noted that in ten years of using
volcanoes in their patients there have
been zero complications from
lactobacilli in their patient population
so this brings me to my main research
question and that is how enclosed
bacteria protect against
Fasil so we believe that the Achilles
heel of C difficile pathogenesis is in
its susceptibility to secreted
antimicrobial Spidy host microbiota and
that we could use specific probiotic
formulations and minister them to
patients at high risk of developing CDI
and that that may in fact decrease
disease incidents in this vulnerable
patient population we know that patients
on antibiotics have an increased
relative abundance in the presence of
lactobacillus a CD lactobacillus EA is
the family of bacteria that contain
lactic acid bacteria the interesting
thing here is that an abaya
treatment creates an environment that's
selected for lactic acid bacteria lactic
acid bacteria happen to be intrinsically
resistant to most antibiotics that we
use today and so these organisms while
resistant they're intrinsically or
naturally resistant which is
non-transferable and by targeting a
lactic acid bacteria the probiotic we
are using in an organism that could
withstand an environment that is fought
with antimicrobials the lactobacillus
are Blackduck for lactic acid bacteria
are central in Jo my GI microbiome
DeBell
now the human research spinning out of
microbiome research initiatives by
dominguez demo at all has shown that
just simply delivery differences in
delivery of children at birth can change
their microbiome initially so when you
look at this graph here on on the right
hand side of their screen you can see
that there are these circles
representing micro biomes of babies or
the micro biomes of their mothers and in
light pink you can see that these babies
were delivered vaginally and have
microbiomes very similar to their
mother's vaginal microbiota which is
mostly made up of lactobacilli in lactic
acid bacteria on the other hand you have
microbiomes represented in blue and
these babies and represented by the
light blue circles were delivered by
caesarian and their microbiomes more
readily mimic those microbiota on the
skin and not necessarily specifically
the mother's skin microbiota so we can
see here that by normal delivery babies
are initially colonized with vaginal
microbiota and that consists of a lot of
lactobacillus additionally after a
vertical transmission of lacquer to
select a literature child we also have
additional sources of lactic acid
bacteria that contribute to the
microbiome development of the GI tract
and that's breast milk cigarette smoke
is an eternal source of microbes is rich
in lactic acid bacteria and it provides
a secondary inoculation and also
nutrition joining with that GI
so based on this information we decided
to determine whether or not there were
lactic acid bacteria or also probiotic
known probiotic organisms that may be
resistant to antimicrobial drugs that
are currently used to treat clustering
difficile infection when thinking about
using a probiotic to target the
prevention of an antimicrobial
associated disease it's important that
your probiotic organism is able to
withstand the harsh antimicrobial
treatments the patients might already be
taking so we've looked at several
different probiotic organisms
lactobacillus royally lactobacillus k-ci
like a bacillus rhamnosus and
lactobacillus caesarea and we were able
to show you that lactobacillus writerly
was our most resistant probiotic to
drugs currently used to treat c
difficile infection and on my
antibiotics of income i assume that AXA
myosin and metronidazole are currently
the most common antibiotics used to
treat city fazil and lactobacillus
really is highly resistant at minimum
inhibitory concentrations significantly
greater than those used to kill students
ill so with that we have focused our
efforts on characterizing lactobacillus
reuteri streams as a potential probiotic
for prevention of students ill infection
now lactobacillus reuteri is a known
probiotic it has been characterized
extensively in the literature and never
been shown
to be associated with disease its
indigenous to the GI tract of many
mammals and birds and has also been
isolated from human breast milk human
derive strains produced a variety of
factors beneficial to human health and
those include the prediction of the
antimicrobial specifically the enema
cobia loitering and it's been shown to
be inhibitory to specific GI pathogens
lactobacillus really can produce
vitamins in this case our human drive
strains produce vitamin b12 and
additional many specific strains of
outlawry can produce histamine in the GI
tract which works as an implement
inflammation modulator is able to
suppress inflammation in the host in a
earlier study we took some genetic
information from several isolates
lactobacillus reuteri strains which are
called genomes and did whole genome
comparisons to get a better idea of
these specific traits inherent to
different groups of our arteries strains
that have evolved down different paths
to determine whether or not one stream
might be more suited for our use in
antimicrobial associated disease
prevention
so this slide basically it's going to
help you understand the data I show you
on the next slide we did paralyze
genomic comparisons whole genome
comparisons looking at the similarity in
nucleotide sequence as well as in
similarity in gene content and when we
take a look at the data in this way and
plot it in a graph similar to what you
see on this slide we are able to
determine whether or not specific
strains have evolved in different
violence and how different their gene
content might be from one another if if
data is represented here on the graph
you can see that they have less
nucleotide similarity at the base pair
resolution level as well as less gene
content similarity showing that they
would have a variety of different traits
that helped them survive in their
environment if you find data plotted
closer to the origin of the graph they
have very similar gene content and may
create identity so based on these kinds
of analyses looking at several genomes
of lactobacillus reuteri derive from
three different hosts we were able to
show that as expected you might know
that gene content and DNA similarity are
quite different but when comparing
lactobacillus reuteri species that have
co-evolved with different hosts you're
looking at this craft
Armel left the different colors
represent different hosts the
lactobacillus reuteri strains isolated
from humans and represented by blue
diamonds
while lactobacillus reuteri genomes that
were isolated from strains derived from
pigs are represented by red stars we
also have lactobacillus reuteri
excellence farm eliminates represented
in the green circles the cluster of data
shown here in this portion of the graph
indicates that the genomes of these
strings are quite different while they
are similar enough to be considered
lactobacillus burglary of the same
species
they are not as
identical as genomes isolated from the
same host interestingly when we look at
the second wrapped closer to the right
removing for all genomes from other
non-human hosts and look at different
groups lactobacillus reuteri
actually from humans we can see
immediately that the different groups or
clades as they're referred to on the
graph are just as different from each
other so for example claim to vs. clade
6 comparisons are not as identical as
one might think
additionally when you compare a clade 6
versus a clade 6 you can see that it's
very similar so while these kinds of
whole genome comparisons give us insight
into how different host derived speech
strains of lactobacillus rotary are we
wanted to look closer at specific human
derived lactobacillus reuteri so in the
graph on the right we have eliminated
all genomes derived from strings from
Hume from hosts like pigs and rodents
and just specifically are looking at
human derived strains and if you
remember in the graph in in the tree I
showed a couple of songs ago there were
two specific clades or groups of human
derived l rotary and when we compare
genomes between those two clades play 2
& 6 we can see that genomes from these
two clades are as different from one
another as they are from genomes of
strings isolated from
or rodents so this gave us our first
clear evidence that while human derived
lactobacillus reuteri are known to be
probiotics and they have a variety of
beneficial characteristics these
characteristics are definitely strain
specific and unique to specific
evolutionary groups of lactobacillus
reuter II so this slide summarizes some
of the different probiotic
characteristics of human derived
lactobacillus reuteri you can see that
they both both groups of Elmarie produce
anime Chromeo called loitering one group
produces it better than the other these
groups produce vitamins variety of
vitamins vitamin b12 vitamin b2 b1 and
folate
and additionally immunomodulatory
factors are produced by both groups of
human drive lactobacillus rotary while
we have identified others have
identified the molecule histamine as
anti-inflammatory factor produced by the
clade to avert any strains we know that
other factors unknown are produced by
the clade 6 our earrings and impact
immune function on the host for the
remainder of my talk I'm going to focus
on the production of loitering by
lactobacillus rotary and how we can
exploit that beneficial characteristic
to target kind of biotic associated c
difficile infection
in previous work I was able to show that
Roy Turing produced by a variety of
lactobacillus Roy dueling strains was
capable of inhibiting enteric pathogens
so on this graph you're looking at the
percent growth of a particular enteric
pathogen whether it be a heck DTEC
Salmonella enterica Shigella Sonia or
Vibrio cholerae you can see when no
loitering is in the assay that you have
100% growth of the pathogen if we use
loitering produced from one of four
different of rotary strains indicated
here we are able to inhibit the growth
of each of these pathogens by 95 percent
[Music]
loitering is the antimicrobial compound
produced by lactobacillus royalty it is
a small molecule
it contains absolutely no protein
component and it is produced during
glycerol fermentation by a vitamin b-12
dependent glycerol dehydratase loitering
has been characterized in the literature
to have broad-spectrum effects it can
inhibit gram-positive and gram-negative
bacteria as well as some yeast and fungi
and when we come the genetic elements
responsible for loiter and production
are present in a 58 gene cluster that
was acquired by horizontal gene transfer
these genes the cluster of genes here on
the right on the left are important for
the conversion of glycerol to loiter and
there is an epoch our gene that's
important for
activating transcription of the genes in
this gene cluster there's the glycerol
dehydratase
that is directly responsible for
converting glycerol or later on and the
second arm of this gene cluster is
required for de novo vitamin b12
synthesis and the organism uses the
vitamin b12 produced here to activate
the glycerol dehydrogenase which then
converts goats are all to Lauren now we
need to see this gene cluster and all of
our human derived strains to date they
are different and amino acid identity
between the two plates that I've been
describing throughout the talk and they
have different capabilities these two
groups have different capabilities of
producing reuter and most likely due to
the genetic differences seen in the 58
gene cluster so when we look at a
variety of strains in each clade you can
see that strains from clay to produce
letter and but far be it lower levels
than strings in clade 6 and the based on
this day only decided to move forward
and testing prototypical strains from
each clade and their ability to inhibit
c difficile infection
so when we look at lactobacillus Reuter
II and its ability to inhibit c
difficile we were very pleased we found
that in fact we're doing doesn't have it
c difficile you're looking at some
overlay assays here on the left hand
side we're testing two strains a clade
six string which is called one seven
nine three eight and i played two strain
which is referred to as 6-4 7-5 you can
see in these plates that elder-tree is
spotted for you rotary is spotted here
and developed in a spot on the media c
difficile is then overlain on these
spots in a soft agar where it's allowed
to grow as a lawn in the top layer and
when glycerol is available to
lactobacillus rotary as we've made it in
this assay it came from vocalist roger
loitering and then results in the zone
of clearance that you see around the
rotary spot which is indicating that
loitering is produced and capable of
inhibiting the growth at c difficile
when we knock out or make a mutant in
lactobacillus rotary imaging that
responsible for activating the gene
expression of the fifty-eighth gene
cluster we also prevent rotor and
production by l rotary which then is
giving us a strain or that is incapable
of inhibiting c difficile infection
additionally what we're showing in this
assay is a disk that contains 5 micro
pounds
a myosin if you'll remember earlier in
my talk I mentioned that mega myosin is
one of the drugs used to treat C
difficile infection and you can see here
a zone of clearance showing inhibition
of C get the snow and the really a key
point for us is that the lactobacillus
really strain one seven nine three eight
and production of loitering by the
strange was capable of inhibiting C
difficile and a far greater manner than
the vancomycin disc the drug currently
used to treat additionally what we're
showing here is that there's strain
specific effects in him in the
inhibition I'm going to call your
attention to the graph here at the top
right and this is showing order of
production by these two strains you can
see that here this clade six isolate one
seven nine three eight is anal trip
reduce significantly greater amounts of
loitering than the clay two or six or
seven five strain and this phenotype
coincides nicely with the inhibition
that we see in the zones of clearance by
these two strings so you can see that
our clade six isolate that is capable of
producing the most rotary is also
capable of inhibiting C difficile the
best so with this we have gone on to ask
whether or not we can see inhibition of
C difficile in microbial community these
are nice in vitro assays that give us a
proof of concept but when you mix the
probiotic and the pathogen amongst a
variety of other
would the phenotype still hold true and
so in order to get at this question we
teamed up with other investigators over
at Baylor dr. Robert Britton and
Jennifer Ogden they have a mini
bioreactor array system and assay
developed specifically to look at c
difficile invasion of microbial
communities so in this assay they use
fecal human fecal content to inoculate
these small containers or many bio
reactors they will culture fecal content
in these bio reactors disrupt them with
antibiotics inoculate with CDF and watch
CF monitor scenic levels as time goes on
we teamed up with these investigators to
test whether or not the treatment of a
biotic treated community with
lactobacillus reuter II and its
substrate glycerol could in any
effective prevent C difficile from
growing in these microbial communities
so in our experiment maybe followed this
timeline that you can see here at the
bottom of the screen these bio reactors
were inoculated with people content and
allowed to establish a community over a
day flow was started after 24 hours and
the community
established over a couple of days after
a few days the bioreactors were treated
with klenda myosin an antimicrobial
known to generate susceptible on
microbial communities communities
susceptible to C difficile invasion
after antibiotic treatment we decided to
test four groups we had control reactors
that received seed officiel alone just
to show that our microbial communities
that have been disrupted by antibiotics
could in fact support the growth of the
pathogen we had reactors that receive
lactobacillus reuter e to see if just by
combining Alberti in these communities
we could inhibit c difficile infection
we had reactors that received only the
substrate glycerol and then reactors
that received of the substrate glycerol
and lactobacillus Reuter e to determine
whether or not active production of
Reuter and in a microbial community
could prevent C difficile infection this
slide basically is showing that
microbial communities generated in these
bio reactors mimic those that we see in
patients with C difficile infection
here on the Left I'm showing you an
alpha diversity plot indicating that in
bio reactors before antibiotics you have
similar you have similar numbers of
species seen in these fire reactors
without antibiotics as compared to
individuals healthy individual fecal
samples additionally after antibiotic
treatment you see a decrease in the
amount of observed species in reactors
that is similar to what you see in
patients who have been on antibiotics
and diagnosed with cluster Abell
difficile infection additionally when we
look more globally at microbial
community structure it'll be here on the
right you can see here at the bottom
what I'm showing you is basically the
kinds of bacteria that are associated
with healthy pediatric Rico specimens so
the nodes in the center of this cluster
of shapes and colors represent patients
or healthy healthy children nas
specimens and the squares on the outside
are the kinds of bacteria that are
associated with these healthy
individuals when we look at the bacteria
associated with patients that have been
diagnosed with C difficile infection
shown here in red you can see a definite
shift in the kinds of bacteria that are
associated which are indicated by the
different colors here when we look the
same way at the community's present in
the bioreactors we see very similar
types of bacteria associated with
bioreactors before antibiotics and after
antibiotic treatment you see a shift in
community members that mimic what we see
down here in
mutation microbiota so overall this
Mooney bioreactor a and C difficile
infection model mimics what we see in
human hosts and is a good model for us
to be able to study this kind of
treatment in vitro so narrow I'm showing
you data from our bio reactor array
experiment recall that we had many
bioreactor race that established their
communities for a few days before any
manipulations and you can see their
microbiome represented here the groups
in red represent control reactors that
only received antibiotics and C
difficile shapes colored in green were
also infected with C difficile and
received antibiotic treatment but also
we're given lactobacillus rotary shapes
in bloom received lack of a sorority and
glycerol and in theory were capable of
producing loitering and shapes in black
received to the substrate alone with no
probiotic lactobacillus rotary in the
beginning before any manipulation you
can see that the untreated human fecal
communities from all reactors cluster
together and show that they have very
similar microbial communities after
antibiotic treatment all reactors
communities in the reactors shifted
similarly and are shown here in this
group after the addition of glycerol we
can see a second shift and that's
represented here in the shapes that are
colored blue and black it's not there's
not a recognizable shift and shapes
colored in blue that received both a
rotary and glycerol this is indicating
to us that just by providing glycerol in
the media we have initiated a shift in
microbes that can use glycerol as a
carbon source but the presence of al
rotary doesn't shift this any more
significantly than just a substrate
alone when we look more specifically at
whether or not lactobacillus rotary and
the presence of glycerol can inhibit
c.difficile in these reactors we were
pleasantly surprised I'm using qPCR with
primers specific to C difficile we were
able to show that in our control
reactors and reactors that only would
see del rotary C difficile was able to
take hold in these communities I'm
showing you here control in red over 3
and green and after C difficile
inoculation host antibiotic treatment C
difficile counts increased significantly
you can also see that C difficile counts
increase quite a bit with the presence
of cholesterol so glycerol is not
specifically in heavens and c difficile
growth and while these counts seem a
little bit higher than the controlling
actors the data is not significantly
different the most important piece of
information from this data is the fact
that when we provide lactobacillus
reuteri
and glycerol together we see a signal
decrease in mobility of Sina bazzill to
grow in these lack of microbial
communities this is indicating to us
that from the previous slide where we
did not see a significant shift in
microbial community structure in the
presence of both award and glycerol we
do see a specific decrease in C
difficile colonization on these
microbial communities and furthermore
when we test the ability of
lactobacillus rotary and glycerol to
inhibit c difficile ex-vivo we have the
same results so in experiments using
germ-free mouse feces we were able to
show that by providing lactobacillus
reuteri and the substrate was wrong we
can in fact inhibit c difficile from
growing in this media so with this we
are hopeful that we are on to something
important that lactobacillus reuteri
approval erotic given the proper
substrate could be used as a potential
primitive treatment to C difficile
infection so our current and future
directions continue to develop
next-generation probiotics which are
defined as commensal derived bacteria
that will make specific health claims to
treatment prevent disease and the
probiotic the next-generation probiotic
of interest here is one that's designed
specifically to prevent C difficile
infection in
is patient populations additionally
we're interested in automated optimizing
our delivery strategy strategies
currently lactobacillus rotary is
provided in formulations as a single
strain or in combination with another
strain but if we could devise
formulations that included the substrate
glycerol in a manner that precluded
other organisms in the GI tract from
utilizing the substrate specifically
directing it to overly allowing in order
to synthesize the antimicrobial
loitering and target this to the colon
the site of infection that we could
further benefit from the development of
this next-generation probiotic
so in summary I've discussed beneficial
microbes and our specific efforts at
using targeted probiotic strategy at
preventing an antibiotic associated
disease and this kind of new therapy
would be crucial in fighting our current
antibiotic resistance crisis with C
difficile infection now being treated
with antibiotics it's initially caused
by the use of antibiotics and then
further treated by subsequent antibiotic
use if we could in theory use a
probiotic formulation that would prevent
C difficile infection in patients on
antibiotics we could also in theory
decrease the use of further further use
of antibiotics that would be required to
treat a subsequent
so in that I would like to offer some
acknowledges to the funding agencies the
NIH the Texas Children's microbiome
Center for supporting this work and my
collaborators tour savage rob Britton
and Jennifer achtung additionally a
special thanks to Aaron Brown who is my
right hand in the lab and has provided a
lot of the effort going towards the data
I've shown you today thank you thank you
dr. Spindler for that informative
presentation it's time for Q&A if you
have a question you'd like to ask please
do so now just click on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click on the send button we'll
answer as many of your questions as we
have time for if we are unable to get to
your question we will follow up with you
via email after the presentation let's
get started
our first question is can Roy Turing be
supplied directly to inhibit c.difficile
so Reiner in as a small molecule it is
it is a reactive aldehyde and it is
extremely reactive we have done
experiments where we have tried to
provide Reuter and in the mini bio
reactors directly and inhibit seed of
the co however this has been
unsuccessful and our thoughts on this
are that loitering is immediately
deactivated as it's added to the
bacterial communities so in our
experience this treatment method
requires the live probiotic and the
availability of the substrate to work in
concert during an active infection so
the short answer is no we can't at this
time use Reuter into directly tree to
the infection
thank you is there any concern that Elle
rotary could transfer their resistance
to the antibiotics used to treat c
difficile so that's a great question
we are definitely as I've mentioned
worried about the transfer of
antimicrobial resistance and our lack or
inability to be able to contain
resistant organisms the nice thing about
lactic acid bacteria is that they are
intrinsically resistant so they have not
acquired their resistance
characteristics from other microbes they
are just naturally resistant and these
natural mechanisms of resistance are not
considered to be transferable they don't
exist on mobile elements of DNA that can
readily exchange between organisms so
the ability of Elverta to withstand they
kamiya-san maximize and metronidazole is
due to their natural resistance and
is thought to be highly unlikely that it
could be transferable
thank you for that answer we'll wrap up
with one last question and that question
is if fecal microbiota transplantation
works to treat recurrence c difficile
infection why do we need specific
probiotics to prevent this disease
thanks Julie that's another great
question it is true that right now a lot
of institutions are using people
microbial transplantation to treat
patients with severely current CDI the
idea behind this therapy is that they
are able to completely replace the
diseased and disrupted microbiota of the
impacted individual with microbes from a
healthy individual and this is enough to
take care of the infection that they
continue to recur after multiple rounds
of antibiotics we are just beginning to
understand the kinds of downstream
fallout that can occur from an activity
of people microbial transplantation when
we do these kinds of transplants we
don't know exactly everything that we're
transplanting there could be downstream
long-term health effects that result
from these kinds of transfers for
example there is a documentation in the
literature showing that a woman who
received fmt from her relative became
overweight after after the treatment so
just as we've seen in mice if you
transfer eco material from obese
to lean mice you can result in creating
an obese Mouse that never had a weight
issue there's also been reports of
transference of high blood pressure and
other kinds of disease so while we are
able to screen the fecal microbial con
material for pathogens that we know of
and we've screen the donors by diet and
BMI and other very specific health
factors we still are transferring a lot
of unknown content into our patients and
right now FM T is basically a band-aid
we're using it because we need it and we
have to and that's what's saving
patients but it shouldn't be the long
term treatment option we should strive
to have better specific cleaner
treatment modalities
I would like to once again thank dr.
Spindler for her presentation you have
any final comments Thank You Julie I
appreciated taking the time today to be
able to share my work with lab roots and
your respective audience I hope that
I've left you with enough information to
understand how probiotics and beneficial
microbes might be of use to future
medical medical questions and how we aim
to use specific strains with specific
characteristics to fight a specific
disease so thank you very much
thank you once again dr. Spindler I
would also like to thank lab roots for
making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through December 14th 2017 you will
receive an email from lab roots letting
you know when this webcast will be
available to replay please share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us we hope to see you again soon goodbye